Alors, combien ils étaient ?
Bah, il y en avait plusieurs...
Y en avait là...
Y en avait environ là...
Y en avait derrière...
Et... et là aussi ?
Et là aussi.
Et y en avait là.
OK.
Donc "Y en..."
"avait..."
"là".
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
T'as quel âge ?
L'âge de plus être difficile.
Ça tombe bien, moi aussi.
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
Football, maintenant nous sommes en direct avec...
...Michel.
Michel, est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler les scores ?
Non !
Merci, Michel.
On continue tout de suite avec une course de Formule...
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
Vous rouliez à combien là, Monsieur ?
Oh, à vitesse raisonnable.
Ouais...
C'est limité à pépère, hein.
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
[Toc toc]
Rentrez.
Vous êtes en retard !
Il est p'tite aiguille en bas et grande sur la droite !
Eh ben voilà... Jamais un p'tit peu sans un peu plus...
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
J'aimerais bien te revoir, tu peux me donner le moyen de t'appeler ?
Oui, bien sûr.
C'est touche du bas,
touche du milieu droite,
gauche, oui, exactement...
grande diagonale à droite...
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
Bonsoir !
Je vous rappelle que pour ce tirage, et bien la somme à gagner est de
Oh putain sa mère j'suis riche je démissionne et j'te quitte !
Bonne chance à tous !
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
On passe à l'histoire.
Vous prenez vos livres à la page pas-tout-à-fait-à-la-fin-mais-presque,
on va parler de la guerre d'y a pas très longtemps,
quand mon grand-père était jeune, avec les étoiles jaunes.
UN MONDE SANS CHIFFRE
Eh ben... vous êtes "bien bourré".
BWAAH !
Excusez-moi ?
Oui ?
Vous l'auriez en taille "gros boule" ?
Il nous reste que des "p'tit derche"...
Désolée.
WHAAAAAAAAAA !
Demain matin il fera "on se pèle les couilles dans la région du Havre..."
AH !
Ça va pas ?
J'ai fait un cauchemar.
Ah bon ?
Oui, c'était horrible, on vivait dans un monde sans chiffre...
Mais il y avait les lettres ?
Bah oui, oui...
Toutes ?
Oui, toutes, les 26.
Ah.
Le compte est bon.
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, on est déjà beaucoup moins d'abonnés que Norman et ça, ça fait vraiment plaisir.
Et sinon, tous les vendredi, sur le site, y a les vidéos du Lab à l'heure de la p'tite aiguille en bas et la grande en haut.